I'm hearing stories of non-political
channels and like YouTubers and
influencers for no reason just being
like Oh I'm not woke by the way like I'm
not I'm gonna do any of that yeah
because they're worried about not being
popular and there are some watershed
moments that led to that I mean the
Dylan Mulvaney I agree with 100 was was
in this movement
um kovid I think it was when Joe Rogan
said that CNN when they said on CNN that
Joe Rogan was taken horse dewormer and
that's when Joe Rogan was like are you
kidding me like like this and he it was
such a viral moment that everyone
realized oh wow CNN just lies about
these things and and so yeah that's when
the people in the crowd are starting to
realize they're not telling us all the
truth here are they and the more this
happens the better it is for society but
it's why platforms like this are
important it's why Joe Rogan's important
it's my alternative media is important
lying about Joe Rogan is a bold move
yeah he could he I mean he has such a
massive platform he can so easily
disprove it and there were other ways
that the media be clowned themselves
through the covid pandemic